I
World of Tanks will change greatly in
2014 we've already told you about the
new physics and graphics that will
improve the beauty and atmosphere of the
game now let's talk about features that
will bring more diversity into battles
new game modes
it has been long known that the current
global map is not enough most provinces
are controlled by a number of top plans
for most glands it's almost impossible
to win a landing tournament and there is
not much to do on the global map but to
fight over the provinces something
needed to be done we developed a brand
new feature and called it fortification
we've decided that fortifications will
be given to all clans in the game there
will be a certain minimum number of clan
members for a clan to get its
fortification a clan with only one
player doesn't need a fortification
because this player won't be able to
defend it and their fortifications clans
will be able to construct buildings
different buildings will give different
economic bonuses to construct them plans
will need resources this is a new type
of currency and clans will have to fight
with each other to obtain it after each
type of building has been constructed
the so-called reserves will appear in
the fortification reserves will be like
small events for the clan that owns that
fortification for example combat pay
will give a ten percent bonus for
credits in every battle including random
battles for three or four hours bonuses
could be different there could be credit
bonuses or bonuses to experience or free
experience which bonuses are available
will depend on how clans develop their
fortifications in this game mode there
will be an enticing but fateful
opportunity clans will be able to not
only build fortifications but also to
ransack them to protect new clans from
more experienced and strong ones the
mode of attack and defense will be
available only when a fortification
reaches its fifth level of development
this new game mode will be independent
from the current global map
fortifications will have nothing to do
with it clam players can fight for their
fortifications and take part in battles
on the global map these are two
independent opportunities players can
fight in both game modes or they can
choose one they can choose neither at
all it depends on their preferences
fortifications will provide a number of
opportunities that are not available and
won't ever be available in other game
modes this is not only about managing
the fortification this is also an
opportune
you use brand new features on the
battlefield players will be able to call
in bombers conduct reconnaissance lay
mines or install pill boxes that will
perform the role of additional artillery
forces these features will diversify the
battles and make them more remarkable
and unique now players will not only
focus on their vehicles but also pay
attention to what's happening around
them basically fortifications will
create a parallel universe in World of
Tanks a game within the game work on
improving this game mode will continue
historical battle mode discussed almost
since the day the game was first
released will finally appear in the 9.0
update the main problem of historical
battles was to develop a good system of
vehicle matchmaking in real battles
tanks that fought against each other
differed greatly and their capabilities
for example the KD 1 and the t-34 with
76 millimeter guns fought against tigers
for quite a long time the powerful
German heavy tanks were overcome with
artillery air forces infantry and
landmines there are no such things in
the game so developers had to look for
other ways of balancing teams one of the
solutions is unequal team members this
means that one team may have 15 vehicles
while the other may have only 3 the
scheme was applied in the first version
of historical battles which was tested
on the common test servers it turned out
that this scheme was not sufficient to
balance the chances of the teams so we
had to make additional changes in
historical battle mode vehicles
specifications such as maneuverability
speed and view range will be different
from what they have in other game modes
probably most importantly the number of
hit points will change heavy vehicles
will be easier to destroy earlier in the
process we tested the prototype of
historical battle mode that did away
with vehicle hit points to destroy a
vehicle you had to knock out all of its
modules or put all of its crew members
out of action this approach made the
game worse we understood that players
would become frustrated
they didn't understand why they kept
firing at enemy tanks for a long time
but the enemy tank just wouldn't get
destroyed and other times the very same
vehicle might be destroyed with a single
shot sometimes we watch two tanks just
standing and firing at each other for
more than two minutes with no
consequences in the first minutes of the
battle vehicles usually had about half
of their modules knocked up after
several battles everyone realized that
the best tactic was to hide and wait
almost until the end of the battle and
then finish off the damaged vehicles
there's a third-party mod that displays
zones of penetration on the vehicle
model if we make this game mode too
realistic everyone might feel forced to
play with this mod however the next
variant of team matchmaking in
historical battles is about to be
released and that upcoming system each
team will have several main heavy
vehicles and a larger number of lighter
support vehicles for example one team
with a few Tigers and a larger number of
pz threes will fight a team with several
kV ones and larger numbers of T 46 s and
BTW sevens we need to make these battles
both playable and interesting to play to
do this we have developed and used of
prototype that allows these lighter
support tanks to respawn into the battle
sometime after they've been destroyed
now these tags will have the freedom to
make mistakes tests showed that these
lighter tanks will try to spot and
attack enemy forces more aggressively so
this respawn system sets the stage for
aggressive tank clashes historical
battles will be introduced as events
that will recreate the real episodes in
history such as the Battle of curse or
the battle of bulge players will be able
to join historical battle only in
vehicles that took part in that battle
in real life vehicles will automatically
be brought to their historical setups
even if you have not researched the
required modules yet players will not
have their choice of ammunition the
number of shells of different types will
be predetermined teams will be assembled
based on nationality for example German
and Soviet vehicles will be on opposite
teams for the Battle of curse everything
will correspond with the real events of
1943 t-34s against tigers and Panthers
the degree of realism in historic
battles is quite moderate consumables
and crew skills and perks even Sixth
Sense will be active playing this game
mode we don't want players to feel like
they're struggling with their own
vehicles they should fight and have fun
while getting the flavor of a historical
battle we want to communicate the
atmosphere of the battle by different
means and we don't want to deprive the
players of the key elements they enjoy
and are used to perhaps all vehicles
that participate in historical battles
will have a feature typical of premium
vehicles players will be able to
transfer their crews from vehicles of
the same type without penalty or
retraining historical battle mode is on
its way another game mode that is
planned for release closer to the end of
the year is garage battle mode in this
game mode players will be able to roll
out several vehicles one by one as they
get destroyed two variants are being
considered the first variant includes
tier 10 vehicles only the second one
allows vehicles of different tiers to
participate to play this game mode
players will need several vehicles of
the same type they will be able to
replenish ammunition and consumables
during the battle however it's too early
to tell exactly what garage battles will
look like details are still being worked
through and haven't been specified yet
along with the introduction of these
three game modes team battle mode will
also be improved in 2014 new features
are being developed to support long-term
teams new online tournaments and special
awards will be introduced the team
battle rules will be updated and many
other small but helpful features will be
introduced that's all for now in the
next episode of developer Diaries we
will tell you how maps will change in
2014 good luck on the battlefield
tankers
you